the poisoning of a double agent in
Britain his daughter and the reaction
today diplomats kicked out of Great
Britain just moments ago the White House
weighing in sera Sandra is releasing a
statement saying this latest action by
Russia fits into a pattern of behavior
in which Russia disregards the
international rules-based order
undermines the sovereignty and security
of countries worldwide and attempts to
subvert or discredit Western democratic
institutions and processes the United
States is working together with our
allies and partners to ensure that this
kind of abhorrent attack does not happen
again saying they side with Great
Britain on the determination that Russia
was behind it with that let's bring in
our panel Steve Hays editor in chief for
the Weekly Standard MOA levy as exec
executive director of the Georgetown
Institute of Politics and Steve Hilton
former adviser to British Prime Minister
David Cameron and host of the next
revolution here on Fox News Channel
Steve the action by Great Britain
obviously they had to do something but
the deadline they installed too or laid
on the ground for Vladimir Putin has
largely been disregarded yes I agree
with all the words they're very nice
words but the actions are frankly
pathetic and will make no difference at
all and it's in line with the West's
handling of Putin for many many years
now going back not just in previous
British governments where he had a
similar sort of poisoning situation with
practically no response at all under the
previous Labour government but also with
US administration's going back to Bush
and then Obama which have just
encouraged Putin's adventurism by
basically doing nothing whatever he does
whether that's walking into Crimea or
Ukraine or whatever it may be this
action by the British is just going
through the motions the diplomatic game
that you play it will make absolutely no
impact on Putin whatsoever and we have
to just get serious because deterring
his adventurism is incredibly important
not just in the context of Russia but
other dictators around the world like
the Chinese who think they can get away
with anything because the West does not
stand up to them
no just before the show the US
ambassador to the United Nations nikki
Haley
with a strong speech at the UN Security
Council this one about a Russia
aggression the Russians complained
recently that we criticize them too much
if the Russian government stopped using
chemical weapons to assassinate its
enemies and if the Russian government
stopped helping its Syrian Ally to use
chemical weapons to kill Syrian children
and if Russia cooperated with the
organization for the prohibition of
chemical weapons by turning over all
information related to this nerve agent
we would stop talking about them she
goes on mode to say the credibility of
this council the UN Security Council
will not survive if we fail to hold
Russia accountable is the talking at
least changing from this administration
I don't know I mean what we're hearing I
thought that was a very strong speech by
ambassador Haley I thought her trying to
hold the Security Council accountable in
its efforts to hold Russia accountable
was a smart move but apply her her words
to the to her boss to president Trump
who does not have very much credibility
right now in holding Russia accountable
yes we need a diplomatic effort we need
to engage the United Nations and the
Security Council but it all rings hollow
if the President of the United States
continues his flirtation with Vladimir
Putin and continues to let him off the
hook
statements by the White House press
secretary and the UN Ambassador no
matter how strong they are do not carry
the same weight as statements by the
President of the United States who has
been silent okay this is what the White
House says to that about this is Sarah
Sanders from couple weeks ago
oh we don't have this well let me tell
you what she says she says that the
actions of the administration that he's
been extremely tough on Russia helped
push through 700 billion dollars to
rebuild him military goes on to say
exporting energy to Eastern Europe
Russia is not excited about it
it keeps the sanctions in place and we
have a Danielle pleco from AEI she was
asked on Meet the Press
about the sanctions regime and how this
administration is handling it she is not
a supporter in the campaign of Donald
Trump infatuation was kind of never
Trump in the campaign but here's what
she said look missile sanctions nuclear
sanctions I have never seen an
administration move so fast as they did
this oligarchs list other lists that if
they put together in fact they have this
is a process and I don't want to defend
the Trump administration where they
don't deserve it but in this case
they've done a lot in other words
actions are they doing a lot yeah I
think in certain sort of fact dating
flicka's right they have done a lot they
could be doing more I mean they have
done a lot they've been arming the
Ukrainians they've they've taken certain
steps that send certain messages but I
agree with Moe I mean I think this
requires a presidential-level statement
the administration has thus far tried
not to get ahead of where the Brits were
on this they wanted our statements to
match the Brit statements as the Brits
got more aggressive the Trump
administration has gotten more
aggressive but there's nothing that
takes the place of a presidential
statement and we all know that when
Donald Trump is unhappy about something
he's very clear about who he's unhappy
with and why he's unhappy we could see
him I would say be tough on this and
also add in a statement about continued
Russia cyber activities against the
United States and its interest around
the world
a warning not to attack US backed rebels
forces in Syria there are many ways in
which the president United States can
send a clear and unambiguous message
that he's had it with Vladimir Putin and
he hasn't done it Steve I would say the
most important thing that can be done is
to hit Putin and Russia where it hurts
and that is in the field of energy it's
correct to say that some
progress has been made on that but I
think actually this administration could
go much much further in helping the
Europeans get rid of their dependence on
Russian energy that also by the way
helps American jobs and industries here
but if you want to see who's colluding
with the Russians for example look at
Angela Merkel she's literally about to
go ahead with a pipeline that buys all
the gas that Putin wants to sell them
that's the kind of thing that actually
just makes Putin think it doesn't matter
what he does it doesn't matter about all
these words in the end he's gonna be
fine because the Europeans are so
dependent on him for energy for all the
aggression that Russia has and for all
of the you know bravado that Putin
brings to everything he talks about he's
not holding a lot of great cards as far
as his own economy and Russia's stance
in economic terms no I think that's
right which is why I agree the United
States has a huge opportunity right now
to to work with our European allies to
put economic pressure on them we're just
not seeing it we're not seeing it from
this sabotaging that it's Merkel that's
standing in the way of that not Donald
Trump so but but the president I states
has a role to play here and he is not
playing it when when he has the the the
nearly unanimous bipartisan support of
Congress to impose economic sanctions on
the Russian government is that much said
it's happening I think we are going to
follow this and maybe we're gonna hear
and see a different thing from the
administration in coming days but we'll
see